I've never gotten more for anything I've
ever done in my life than the Mayo scene
and here it comes
my biggest fear you guys after watching
this scene is that my face will be on a
jar of mayo Oh God
come on Teddy everybody there's my
kimono in a few days I'm getting ready
to get on a plane and go meet rose the
love of my life I got this while
exploring doing furniture manufacturing
in China in 2008 because it's it's soft
it's warm since I met Rose I I want to
look young for her so I have been dyeing
my hair and it irritates my scalp so I
found out that mayonnaise makes it
smoother and less dry that's not a
condom on my head it's a shower cap so I
don't get the mayonnaise on my Italian
leather sofa um big egg mayonnaise will
just make your hair greasy and
disgusting but there is this great stuff
they sell in the stores called
conditioner that makes hair soft while
leaving it you know clean okay well
first of all a lot of the shelf brand
conditioners have a lot of perfume and
they have a lot of really really bad
chemicals so I stay away from anything
that's not natural and look I feel
pretty good at the end of the night
putting something in my hair then I put
on my bacon and lettuce tomato sandwich
okay as long as you wash it out you
don't smell like an egg salad sandwich
[Music]